are about happiness
um I think they're more about compromise
and with compromise comes happiness and
kind of
I guess understanding having that
connection having that empathy having
that chemistry is all ingredients
towards happiness but yeah it's a work
in progress It's a journey that's how I
feel
um
a relationship to some degree a marriage
specifically actually no I think that
happiness is a part it's a component and
it's obviously a byproduct of a happy
and healthy marriage but I think if the
primary goal of a marriage is just based
around happiness emotions are fleeting
so if the only thing holding your
marriage or long-term relationship
together is both people feeling happy
all the time then that marriage is going
to fail because it's not a realistic
goal and I think it's actually a very
childish way to go into it I think if
you have a good happy healthy marriage
then of course you will overall be happy
and be content but I don't think it
should be set up with the intention that
that is going to be the goal all the
time or you're going to fall short of
that because no one can be happy all the
time
yeah I agree I don't think the primary
goal is happiness
um I think it's more about you you know
how you develop independently and then
how you develop together as a unit
um you're never going to be 100 happy I
mean that's the one person that's going
to annoy the [ __ ] out of you like no one
else that's gonna push your buttons but
how you come back from that is basically
what's going to bring that happiness you
know like you know makeup sex and stuff
like that you know so I don't think yeah
like you said if if you're striving for
100 happiness I just think that's fake
that's a fake marriage so I just think
that's not idealistic at all
to me happiness is peace of mind so a
marriage is for you to be in a
partnership that no matter how difficult
or how amazing things are you always
have that peace of mind if things are
bad you're gonna work together to make
them better if things are happy and good
and positive you enjoy them together but
happiness doesn't necessarily mean you
need to have positive things all the
time it's just how you look at things so
my husband baby support me into feeling
positive about most things even when
things are bad
what's the question
I was thinking
is marriage slash relationships about
happiness because nowadays people don't
even get married it's about Duty okay
you know what I'm saying because
obviously when you get married yeah like
obviously it's basically a business
transaction when you think about it like
people get gassed about love love love
bro like bro love is is not
unconditional about there's conditions
to that bro like everyone has to play
their position which is what I'm saying
if you mess up whether it's the man or
the woman brother someone's gonna should
hold you accountable like you know what
I'm saying like bro like this is not
what I signed up for yeah then
especially if you have children involved
but there's even a larger amount of Duty
involved do you get what I'm saying a
lot of us we didn't even come from
families where we come from Marriage you
know what I'm saying or like I know me
personally and most of my friends didn't
come from no home where we had our mom
and dad most of us was just like our mom
you know what I'm saying like so a lot
of us don't even know what it looks like
we've not experienced it so
like not to not to be funny but like
when I hear people's
um like idea of what it is like most of
us don't even really know we're just
we're just saying what we think in it
like but is that really what it is
because
um if you ask people from the 1950s they
probably have something different to say
you know what I'm saying so like that's
just
realistically I'm not married I haven't
been married I don't have kids so I
don't know you know what I'm saying like
I just got an idea of what it may look
like but when I get into it if I ever
get into that yeah it might it might be
something else like you know I mean but
I think more than anything is Duty in it
like as I'm saying if you have that
mindset of his duty you're more inclined
to stick with it you know what I'm
saying so that's what I think
I just think that when two people get
together
but when they go into marriage I just
believe that
a man can't make you happy he's supposed
to be happy and he's supposed to make
you happier same thing goes
their way around because a lot of people
go into relationships or marriage
thinking oh well he or she's going to
make me happy
and they're not happy to start with so I
just think in relationships happiness is
a bonus it's something that you grow to
have
but you've got to be happy before you
enter a relationship and then the person
will make you happier like me I was
always happy my mom makes me happier if
I wasn't with him I'd still be happy but
just not as happy as I am when I'm with
him
foreign
Ty said you have to like and love
yourself before you can like and love
others in it so if you're going to a
relationship like she said it's a bonus
so they're added to your bonus you're
not going in there like expecting them
to make you happy you should be happy in
yourself however that person you meet
you have to understand the uncommisables
and stuff you'll compromise on so when
you're into a relationship you have to
understand that I will compromise on
this I won't compromise on that that's
the reason you get into relationship
knowing that they're good they're bads
and they're uglies if you get in there
naked and you go and they're blindsided
you're going to be oh my God I can't
believe this person like that but when
you get into a relationship again my
brother said it's a it's a financial
commitment it's a partnership commitment
it's all these things mixed in one to
get to where you need to get to and that
happiness comes from yourself but when
they're together and you understand what
they like that's an added bonus to
yourself that's my opinion on it anyway
yeah
well just touching up on what he said
and what Auntie said literally like if
you're not happy within yourself
wait it's going to be very hard to make
yourself happy you know what I'm saying
and if you rely on someone else for the
happiness you've already felt so a lot
of people they don't see that a
relationship is they have their self and
then they got the relationship you get
me so it's like when you come into
relationship you should both be
complimented yourself in different ways
and you should understand that no one's
perfect it got me some people everyone's
got flaws but you need to understand the
flaws that you can tolerate you know
what I'm saying because you can't just
be like oh
from the start in the first three months
it was all good everything that I do
it's always it's always good at the
start you get me but you know delve into
stuff you see two people's colors and
stuff like that you know I have to
understand like yo boom this is the
floors
this is the good you put that together
that's what makes the person the person
you get you can't pick and choose what
you like from someone and then have an
ideology of someone that's where they
just starts getting into like you're
never going to be happy if you're
chasing happiness it's like [ __ ] also
for the swim but it's like people that
take that mad drugs heroin and they
always say like the first time is the
mad and they chase the hit if you're
going to get Happy from the first time
you but that person and then you're just
chasing the happiness all the time you
ain't ever going to be happy so you just
gotta make sure you're happy from the
start
um for me the main things really is like
it's more of a conscious effort to make
your partner happy I mean so there might
be things that you don't want to do but
you do it anyway because you know it's
going to make a person you have happy so
that's the main thing
I
um do not like the word compromise
because compromise means one if not both
members of the party do is not happy
with the agreement I prefer cooperation
right you have to cooperate to get to an
end goal of what you want you know what
I mean so I removed that from it is a
quick little story I had an Uber driver
one time who I he I asked him he was
driving and he was missing his thumb I
said what happened to your thumb just
tell me what happened to your thumb so
we can do this drive because I'm an
[ __ ] and uh he was like oh I got cut
off when I met my wife I said what
happened he said oh dude she was dating
cut my thumb off at a bar fight he's
from Saudi Arabia somewhere um I don't
remember because I don't pay attention
where people are from I don't care and
um she got his finger cut off and he was
14 when he met this woman she was 14.
the guy she was dating was 20 uh but you
know R Kelly and so uh it is what it is
and uh he was like 60 at this point and
I said well what did you do he goes you
know we got this thing as a whole thing
eventually long story short she saved my
fingers she took my finger you to the
hospital where I was they tried to sew
it back on but where I'm from the
medicine was not where it should be and
I said so how long have you been married
I've been married 50 years and I go how
did you not cheat
he goes what do you mean I go I mean how
did you not cheat or leave like 50 years
is a long time to not put your penis
somewhere else no offense ladies uh I'm
sure it's the same for you but it's a
long time to get along he said oh I
don't compromise my wife we cooperate
and it's my duty is what he said and he
said the other thing is
there's not happiness it's not love
every day I don't love her every day I'm
not happy with her every day but I
respect her every day he goes if you
don't respect the person that you meet
and that you marry and that you're with
forever it'll never work he was like
some days I want to throw her through a
wall because I don't like her I don't
love her she said something she pissed
me off she pressed me and I'm over it he
goes but you know what she's the mother
of my children she's been with me for 50
years she took my finger to the hospital
to try to get it sewn back on I respect
this person he goes so that's why I'm
with it and that's why I'm together with
her I forgot the question but that's all
I had to say
the them oh he was I I was 27 at that
point that was 10 years ago and he was
almost 60 then yeah so it's an older
it's an older mindset it's an older
mindset where he said I don't compromise
because that doesn't make any sense I
cooperate with her so we can get to an
end goal because it's that's our duty
and I respect her no matter what she
respects me as well but I respect her
but like my point was like them women of
that generation that's that's different
women bro it's very different it's also
a very different culture than what we're
used to in the west they're the same
women that raised us though it's very
true it's very true but but
yeah wouldn't that be wouldn't that be
our grandparents generation almost
because I don't because it seems like
there's like a change when it's like the
our parents like it seems like our
grandparents like our grandparents were
the ones like Man had side chick across
town she still stayed
my granddad has a whole had two other
whole families yeah and it is what it is
but I don't I don't like growing up my
grandma was my rock right my anything my
mom and dad told me get out of here like
I don't they weren't the parents that
they could have been no offense you know
what they could have been so the way I
look at it is I look at that older
generation I go okay respect Duty and
cooperation is the only way that
long-term thing can can possibly work
like Auntie was saying like everybody
was just saying the happiness is
fleeting that's not gonna say like even
today like we was all joking and
laughing in there but if people saw that
part they would be like how are they
different now like we're very calm
everybody cool now right we was talking
[ __ ] earlier
but I'm saying like even in this moment
even in this room we switched up didn't
we everybody switched up to become be on
camera I got to be cool so it's like
that kind of that energy so I really
respect that everybody you know yeah I'm
not gonna overturn you go ahead
so you know like this is why it's nice
to look at the women but look at the men
as well he said the man the Uber driver
said it's about compromise Iris not
compromises about cooperation I respect
her so it's a duality we can never just
look at the Modern Woman to be the one
that doesn't know how to cooperate
because the man the ones that say
submissions all of this type of stuff so
ham is that's the problem well but I
think I think the idea is that if 70 to
80 percent of women are leaving then
like you start with the 70 to 80 for you
look at the 30. yeah that's great but
surely we want the 70 to turn into like
the 30s everybody to get married his
wife was a housewife she did submit I
don't know if that's important well I
don't know if that's what he's saying he
said no preparation but they cooperated
like how they wanted their relationship
to work so she how does it get to a
point where sometimes you'd be like
sometimes I want to throw it through a
wall 50 years exactly foreign
I think the idea is though in a long
marriage like at the end of the day
someone has to make the final decision
exactly like like someone has to lead
the relationship incorporation and
respect it doesn't come to a veto well
yeah but there's different ways to do it
like okay if there's a CEO of a company
and he knows that this employee is like
disgruntled when he works this way he
may compromise what he wants to do in
order to make the employee happy at
times but it's still his decision
bucks yeah but I still get my will which
means that the disgruntled person the
one that made the complaint and said
this is not cool CEO actually you're
making the wrong decision the CEO will
line a license okay cool which means
that the lack of submission from the
employee actually made the CEO because
it is his decision and that's what I'm
saying right but there's a way to like
bring up
your your disagreements and like a
submissive way where it's like it's like
you you bring it up politely but you
still know he's making the final
decision not you that then comes down to
respect and not submission but why is
being polite submissive exactly is
respect I I think the idea I'm sorry I
might have misspoke but I'm saying like
like because a lot of girls will come
off very argumentative and they they
just want to like get their point across
and just like they're frustrated and I'm
saying like like you can bring up a
concern but the idea is like I trust you
to make the decision I I think a lot of
I think a lot of women I think a lot of
modern women get hung up on the word
submission
yeah it's it's the word itself can we
correct that to our body gets a bit
confused with submission because it's
not just the girls I'm telling you not
blow that up because the mandem thinks
that mission is [ __ ] shut up your mind
no that's not the guys that that's the
kind of God
I'm saying I'm saying okay that's what
other guys said they come for me on the
comments all the time
no I think I think the idea last show
was that you were talking about like you
dated the rapper right now
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
why are you getting informed
so I I approached them first he's got
like the tattoos the gold teeth the gold
jewelries wait did you say you
approached him first yeah you asked what
to him oh okay okay
and I was like okay so he fits a certain
stereotype he looks like a certain way
so he may come across you can make a
judgment but actually hearing what he
has had to say and how he has spoken
he's quite balanced he's he's just a
hardcover but sweet story can I ask can
I ask
is he like a Libra though Yeah well yeah
yeah
tons of times just get some [ __ ] about
my horoscope
you're Pisces in it no oh then Gemini
no see but I would be all those things
back in the days
what is all right guys what is the
biggest lie you've ever told to get laid
that's a good one Vegas
[Laughter]
an initial question of whether love
relationships and marriage were based on
happiness yeah uh no it's based on
practicality and you know Offspring Etc
outside of that I have no real interest
um
I think married you have to actively get
up and say I want this to work like it's
not just going to fall into your lap you
have to look at it like almost a job
like you're going to commit to this
person respect them
take their feelings into consideration
you have to literally get up and
actively work on it every day or it's
not going to work basically
okay so as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible